all right Danica
Danica uh you are an author
you've published a book on
a topic that
covers a lot of
the subject matter that's in my videos
your family you your father
did some things that are probably
described a lot in a lot of my videos
can you can you talk about that a little
bit I can't what's the name of your book
the name of my book is sex offender my
father's Secrets my secret shame and it
came out fairly recently this year in
2022 and
I started writing it when we moved
and we part of the moving process of
course is purging and getting rid of
things and in that process I came across
a box of my father's letters
and
um
it was painful to open up those letters
because there were 17 years of letters
back and forth when he was incarcerated
in a state prison
and
I like to organize and archive and my
husband was with me and we sat on the
floor in the living room and spread out
all of these letters and started
categorizing them by date and year and I
just started rereading them and
recalling the the stories and the pain
and the processing and that language of
loss
and
I talk to my family about it and I said
I think there's a story here
and I believe that there's a story that
needs to be told
from a daughter of a convicted sex
offender
and I'm an English teacher and I've been
writing for years and reading students
writing and I'm encouraging my students
to tell their stories to share their
personal narratives
to dig deeper into
what it is that
makes their lives worthwhile or makes
their lives feel invisible
or makes their lives painful
and I decided to take a risk and took a
big sip from the cup of courage
and started Drafting and creating
chapters and trying to find my voice in
the process because I'm a teacher I
think that initially the voice was very
academic
and in those initial reads of the
manuscript my colleagues and my friends
and even my family kept saying where are
you in this story you keep defaulting to
research and defaulting to that voice
that's detached
um we need to hear you
and that that took a while a couple
years actually for me to
find my voice without shaking
and find the confidence to share the
words sex offender because it's not an
easy thing for me to say
about my father I adored my father I'm
an only child and he was my mentor our
high school softball softball coach
a marathon runner a corporate executive
and a sex offender
so that Paradox was really difficult to
come to terms with
were you one of his victims or no
I I wasn't and I say that with a with a
level of Doubt because when I started
researching sex offending and you've
you've interviewed perpetrators
pedophiles sex offenders
but when I started doing the academic
research
there's a process approach
and it's it's not the man in the white
van handing out candy candy to children
and
on playgrounds or at the mall it's not
the man skulking the Shadows it's it's
not that man
um
my father was a sex offender and
when I was about six years old
I was a victim of sex abuse but not from
my father ironically it was a man in our
neighborhood
and everyone in the neighborhood
congregated at this man's house at this
family's house and part of that
reason why we always wanted to go to
this particular house was that he had
all the things he had the cold Coke and
bottles that I wasn't allowed to have he
had cartoons on constantly which I
wasn't allowed to watch all day long so
we like to go to his house and
that had been going on in this
neighborhood for a while unbeknownst to
me I was only six years old
and one time when I knocked on the door
and wanted to play with his children
which would have been a typical day in
the neighborhood
they weren't there and I thought nothing
as a six-year-old going into the house
because I had been in the house so many
times before
and he asked if I wanted a Coke not the
drug yeah but
um of course I said yes because I wasn't
allowed to have that at my house and he
said well I'm going to go upstairs and
take a shower
and as a six-year-old I didn't think
anything of that because the cartoons
were already running and I was sitting
there with the Coke and I was happy
until I heard him call from the shower
he kept calling my name and I thought oh
my gosh
should I go up there
is he hurt
I should probably go up there but I'm
drinking my Coke and Bugs Bunny is on so
I don't know but anyway I did I went up
there and he was naked and said if if
you want another coat you know you need
to touch me
and I just ran I just ran out of there
but
when I finally told my parents it turned
out that this was An Occurrence that was
happening in our neighborhood for quite
a while
and we went to the police station there
was a private investigator I was six I
didn't know what was going on and that
form of interrogation even as a
six-year-old was so uncomfortable and
foreign and strange and unfamiliar
and my dad at the time
was sitting there the hero right I mean
he was sitting there defending me and
and
supporting me and loving me and and
making me feel safe
but when I started researching this book
it turns out
serendipitously or coincidentally
my dad was sex offending himself
at that same time that I was
being groomed or being assaulted by the
neighbor so I just found those two
timelines
um
so strange that he had been doing it all
along
and I had no idea
because again he went to work every day
he provided for our family he I would
consider him a very clean-cut wears a
suit and tie very charismatic a magnetic
smile
could talk to anyone but he had been sex
offending for
years
throughout my whole childhood and your
mom his wife didn't know
no I really believe my mom did not know
I think that
certainly as an only child my parents
had their different roles in their
marital relationship I think I would
call
my dad the happy and my mom the hammer
my mom was very regimented and she
expected a lot of me as an only child
and had boundaries and restrictions and
rules and my dad was Disneyland my dad
was
the candy Giver the vacation planner the
let's go on the boat and listen to music
he was the Entertainer
and my mom was an intellect she was a
teacher in the Chicago public schools
and she took her work very seriously she
gravitated toward lower socioeconomic
neighborhoods they were tough
neighborhoods she practiced tough love
but she really concentrated and focused
on the students I believe needed it the
most
she was a surrogate mother grandmother
Priestess counselor so she spent an
inordinate amount of time in those
schools in the inner city of Chicago
so I was a latchkey kid
and I was alone a lot but I think that
going back to your question
if my mom had any inkling I think it was
manifested in different ways
so
I think that when I first started
recognizing the marital Discord or a lot
of yelling was really more in my
adolescence not so much in my early
childhood
but I just thought it was dovetailed
with my mom being the hammer because she
had so many rules but she'd yell aloud
at my father and
threatened divorce and I remember one
time in particular
he had taken up a racquetball he was a
very athletic person
and I don't know if he was late or what
was happening but
he should have been somewhere and he
wasn't and he was playing racquetball
and he was in hot water when he came
home and she just
screamed at him and he would just take
it he wouldn't scream back or get
physical or he didn't even raise his
voice she would just pound her fist and
yell at him and he would she was
accusing him of cheating on her and she
took the racket out of his racquetball
bag and flung it against the wall and I
just remember that hole that hole in the
wall being there for months and months
and months I guess just as a reminder of
don't step out of line come home when
you say you're going to come home but I
I could now as an adult it makes so much
more sense her agitation and her sense
of being triggered
um we moved a lot maybe her intuition
was telling her that something was going
on
yeah maybe she didn't know exactly what
it was but
she could sense that something was
yeah I think that she instinctively knew
something was wrong but she stayed with
him and I don't know why that was I
never got really a chance to ask her
because she died of cancer when she was
49 years old so I was 22 and
um there were
pockets and moments in their marriage
that became a little strange again as a
as a preteen as an adolescent for
example during the holidays instead of
having a pair of earrings or I don't
know something else under the tree a
material item to open a box
he started giving her envelopes of money
for Christmas and I thought that was
really odd and I just remember she would
count it and kind of Nod and then just
tuck it away and I thought what is
happening here
there's some sort of transactional
relationship but now all I can think of
the theories that I can think of as an
adult looking back
was she saving to get out of that
marriage was she was she trying to
have a way out I don't know she she
earned an income but not a lot as a
public school teacher and we're a
Catholic Family my father was a very
Pious Catholic so he went through all
the
the Motions of of going to church every
Sunday all the while
sex offending so
how is it for you I mean you found out
at what age that he was doing this
um I was a young mother
full-time teacher so our daughter was
just coming up on a year old you're an
adult already yeah so my mom had had
died of cancer and my dad quickly
remarried someone significantly his
Junior which I didn't like I just
remember
um
him introducing me to her they met at
the grocery store and he had been in her
checkout line for a while throughout my
mom's cancer and I think you know he
kept buying tuna fish and I said why are
you buying all this tuna fish and I
think it was just to go through her line
so that was the only thing that he
thought to Bry was
constant cans of tuna fish but
the first date where he introduced me as
a young adult I was in my 20s to my step
my future stepmom was at a comedy club
and that was probably one of the worst
places you could have taken me as a as a
young adult I didn't laugh once I I
think I squeezed my then boyfriend now
husband's hand until it was you know
white I just I didn't want to be there
at all this wasn't my mother it was too
soon we just had buried her it was like
my dad lost his compass and he clung on
to this new woman so tightly and that's
common when there's trauma when you have
a sense of loss when you've lost your
partner they were married my mom and dad
were married for over 25 years so
I understand it I understand that spiral
was happening but I wasn't accepting it
at the time yeah we got sex offenses
were before that marriage
during
during that marriage before during and
well after he was the thing was going on
when you were a kid too
oh yeah
uh and the reason why I know that is
because of the book I never would have
known until I started asking questions
and inquiries and I interviewed
attorneys social workers Corrections
Officers family friends
um sometimes literally dry heaving at
the at the keyboard
retelling their stories transcribing
their stories is it was
it was horrific you know
because my dad
I loved my dad
and
you know we ran Marathon together and
he came home and and he set out the
cereal bowl and then the spoon and the
list and
everything was in order
and when he dropped to his knees on the
day that he told me that
he was going to turn himself himself in
because
he had touched a six-year-old girl
it was like I had a not a body
experience
and
this is very common for daughters or
Sons or grandparents or siblings when a
sex offender will
tell a half truth or part of the truth
or be a little opaque and give a little
bit
of a confession not a full confession
because that's too hard that's too ugly
that has too many warts and bruises it's
hard
but he told a little bit enough that
obviously landed him
in jail in prison but
we were sitting in the living room it
was a weekend like no other he and my
stepmom were living in a different state
Wisconsin so it's just a couple hours
drive from where we were living
but when they came out of the car that
weekend which was just supposed to be a
casual barbecue watch football weekend
something was dramatically off
I thought maybe he was sick or maybe
they were getting a divorce or maybe he
was bankrupt I mean I I had all those
things went through my head because of
his demeanor he wasn't the buoyant
Smiley let's have a great weekend dad
that I knew
and he got down on his knees
and he started crying and he put his
hands in
he put his head in his hands
and I thought what is happening here
and he said I just I just touched this
little girl but you know what I Danica
I only touched her on her underwear
what
how do you even qualify that I mean I
had a little girl who was napping up in
the room
you only touched her on her underwear
what are you saying I don't
anything else
could you have laundered money or
being a drug addict or anything else but
I will never forget that phrase
it is seared into my memory I only
touched her under underwear
and that's that's grooming that's that's
sex offending that's not necessarily
penetration or touching private parts or
touching girls or boys inappropriately
but that seeing how far you can take it
that's building trust
um as an authority figure as an adult as
a caring person
um
and yeah that that
that should land you in prison
but he was still my dad
he still
had a beating heart
it was this incongruous
relationship
I loved my father
I hated what he did
so I was at this Crossroads as a wife
and a mother and a faculty member and
all the things
do I choose to abandon my father
do I make a choice no longer to speak
with him or communicate because that's a
pretty
that's a choice I could have made
lock them up and throw away the key A
lot of people say that about sex
offenders
with validity
they're probably the most hated
group in a segment of society
yeah I think I think you interviewed you
were saying guys I've researched this
the the trailer park yeah in Florida
yeah St Petersburg yeah there's an
article called pariahville about that
same trailer park and I I'm but they're
everywhere they're everywhere yeah yes
they're not just down in St Petersburg
Florida no they're everywhere because
we're just figuring out how to house
them yes because when you are a
registered sex offender upon transition
from you know a jail or a halfway house
or a prison federal or state
there has to be somewhere you go and
depending on your family or who's left
standing there supporting you waiting
for you or not
um where are you going to work I mean my
dad when he went to jail he didn't go to
prison right away
you went to jail and he was trying to
find a job he lived in a trailer in
Wisconsin
and there was a lot of vigilante justice
in that town because that was the town
where he committed his his offense he
admitted to that right touching the
underwear
and he would often go outside of his
trailer and there was a bag of feces
waiting for him or he would get cat
called or
um called names
horrible horrific names that I won't
repeat
while he was jogging he was he was a
runner and his parole officer would show
up and say you have to you have to
change your running route or this is too
close to the school or whatever it was
there's there's I think being a sex
offender I'm not diminishing it or
supporting it obviously in any way shape
or form I'm a victim of abuse myself
but your world becomes very small when
you're on the registry
and
it's very difficult to find a job to
find housing
much less any type of social life any
friends you know good luck dating
anything like that what have you learned
in doing research for your book
about them
I learned that
there are different layers
of sex offending and I think
the commonality is just to put them in
one container and usually it's a
container far far away on an island
right away from my neighborhood my
school
my area
I did learn that
not to generalize but from the research
that I I was focusing on
geriatric pedophiles elderly sex
offenders because my father was over 60
when he was incarcerated
and I thought at the time this was a one
and done because he told me and he told
the the officers that this six-year-old
girl is is the one that he offended and
he was convicted and he was sentenced
and he was charged with three felony
counts of first degree sexual assault
so basically he would spend the rest of
his life in jail or prison excuse me
but what I learned is that when I looked
back at at my father's actions there was
a lot of coping mechanism something
happened and I don't know what happened
or maybe it was a series of events that
happened in his life but when I was
going back into his particular life and
researching and and talking to family
and friends and
experts
he sang on the radio when he was a kid
he's saying for I think it was called
the
Morris B sacks Amateur hour in Chicago
and he was a tap dancer and he was the
youngest of three boys and I think in
his blue collar
Factory family he was The Golden Child
and I think there was a lot of pressure
on him because of that
and
in this kind of grooming in and of
itself of singing and Performing he kind
of put on a different face he learned
how to work a crowd
and how to be charismatic and how to act
basically from a very young age and then
kind of
as as things progressed uh his brother
died suddenly in a car accident his
middle brother and obviously that trauma
has root in the family his father was an
alcoholic my grandmother worked at a at
a department store so they were
they were probably right above the
poverty line and my dad talked about
that a lot
and just not knowing where the next meal
was going to come from and and
just having a lot of hardships having
hand-me-downs and wearing his brother's
clothes and they had holes in them or he
could he could feel the street beneath
his shoes he never never had a new pair
of shoes or jeans or socks it was always
hand-me-downs and so I think that shaped
his formative years
and when he did go to college to study
architecture like his older brother who
was wildly successful I think he was
always in that shadow in that sibling
shadow
and he dropped out of college
and I think that pressure was too much
so he started selling pencils and
encyclopedias door-to-door
but his whole life was pushing pushing
the boundary pushing the envelope of you
told me I I was gonna be nothing and I
was going to be an alcoholic maybe like
my father or not have any money I'm
going to prove you wrong I'm going to
prove all of you wrong
and he did and I guess in his corporate
life but we moved a lot and now that I
researched for the book
I think we moved partly because of his
job trajectory but I think we moved
mostly because he was offending
and people in the neighborhood found out
and then we just picked up and moved
and then he would start grooming again
and then we just picked up and moved
so we did that until
he couldn't do it any longer but he was
60.
and there was this whole because one of
the attorneys that I interviewed said
why don't you have a Graphic in your
book of a timeline
of the of the victims that you know of
and it started in the 70s but maybe
beforehand I don't know about my
father's fully about my father's sexual
deviance or exploitations because he
never admitted it
in those 500 letters that I referenced
earlier I dug for it I asked him I even
as an English teacher one summer
I assigned him homework I said Dad if
you could just write me about
just just your life just you know what
what
were the best parts of your childhood or
what were the most memorable memorable
parts of your childhood did you ever go
on vacation you never really told me
about that
and he wrote me probably over 25 pages
of what he called installments of his
life these installments of his life in
every installment it was like this
extrinsic motivation of well I remember
when I first started in Cub Scouts and
then I was in Boy Scouts and then I
earned Eagle Scout which is the most
prestigious award you can earn as a
scout
and then when I sold pencils you know
because I he he even glossed over
College he said well I was the social
chair in my in my fraternity and he
didn't say I dropped out of college or
none of that you know I was a social
chair in my fraternity and I met your
beautiful mother and she was the prize
your mom was the princess at University
of Illinois
she was a synchronized swimmer she had
legs like a ballerina and and she had so
many dates when I met her and I said put
that date book away I'm going to be the
only man in your life so it was always
about the gold star the award the trophy
the accolade
was he overcompensating was he trying to
fill a void that he couldn't fill
so it just continued so
um my mom kept some scrapbooks of his
corporate life and it was a
picture of an internal newsletter about
him being promoted or it was a trip to
Switzerland or a trip to Taiwan he was a
domestic and international marketing
person he he sold office supply office
supplies
and he would come home for example from
Taiwan and of course now I'm dating
myself but he brought home this Walkman
this yellow hard plastic Walkman and it
was the first mobile music of the time
you could walk around and listen to
music and all my friends on the Block
thought my dad was just
he was it because he was bringing me all
these
eccentric and cool products from
around the world
so I think he really thrived on that but
I think it was all a mask for what he
was feeling inside
what have you learned what did we not
understand about sex offenders
we all make assumptions about them but
what do we What would
the rest of the public
be surprised at learning about them
I think the common denominator that I
found is
love is that they feel somehow unlovable
or not worthy
and
in that lack of self-worth
it manifests into evil and it transforms
into control
and dominance
and Trust
and
it's an illness I mean it's it's in the
American Psychological Association as a
mental illness
and I do believe that that's the
um
misrepresentation of sex sex offenders
that
my mom died of a physical illness she
died of of cancer that metastasized to
her bones and her organs
I believe my dad died of a mental
illness and next week is
mental Global Mental Health Awareness
Day October 10th every year
and I think
it's those times and everything in
between that we really need to pause
because
there are so much Social stigma against
sex offenders with good reason they are
harming innocent lives
but they're still people
and I just don't know that
a state or federal
prison sentence is moving the needle
I don't know what the Panacea or
solution is but
is it Rehabilitation is it castration is
it therapy I mean my dad went to a
handful of sex offender therapy sessions
before he went to prison
once you went to prison that was cut off
I was no longer available
so those 18 sessions where his certified
expert counselor said he's good to go
I mean I I don't understand that it's
it's a Continuum it's it's a it's a
lifelong work is it something that's
curable you think
no I I don't think so personally
um I think it's a lot of I think it
possibly could be curved
I think a lot of it is impulse control
this impulsivity and
this grade of I I touched your underwear
and then I had her sit on my lap and
then I touched her up above and then you
know I mean I think it just goes and
stages I don't necessarily think it's
all at once like many people do
but again there's different degrees now
there's tears that Adam Walsh act
um in 2006 I believe in my father's
sentencing and everything was predated
that so there were no tears at that time
but if you read that act and you look at
the different tiers of sex offenders
which which varies from state to state
but at least it it gives a little more
information
about what it could be and that's what I
that's what I would say about sex
offending is
be open with your family with your
children
with their cousins talk about it and
it's not necessarily again the Boogeyman
in the dark it could be like you've
interviewed
the police officer or the really nice
next door neighbor
and if that person is going to Great
Lengths
to
interact with your children
I would all pick them up from soccer
or I'm just you know what I'm taking my
daughter out for ice cream I'll just
take yours too if that seems off to you
instinctively it probably is
and certainly you can look on the
Nationwide sex offender registry and see
you know in your neighborhood how many
sex offenders there are
but I think it's definitely worth the
discussion those are the ones that have
been convicted yes there's a lot that
have never been caught those are the
ones that have been convicted and are
documented and even then even then I
mean the story is
it goes on with my father but
he was granted a state transfer which is
highly unusual
and he was given a second chance and he
moved in with his brother in Georgia and
I never really knew if he registered in
Georgia I think he did because you you
have to register if you're moving from
state to state you have to register in
every state but he was given a second
chance
and it didn't take long
and he started grooming a girl in the
neighborhood right he lived with his
brother and then he convinced his
brother you know what we're good I'm
good I'm gonna get my own place enough
of The Odd Couple uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
strike out on my own and and he started
offending again and that's when things
really turned upside down for our family
and
this can happen to any family but you
never think it's going to happen to your
family I try not to give my opinions on
these kind of topics in my on my channel
but it every time I hear these stories
they do so much damage
to young people and it seems like
castration which is whether it's
chemical or however they would do it
seems like such a sensible solution is
it not
because that they wouldn't be they
wouldn't have the drive impulse they
wouldn't have the impulse to do it any
longer and doesn't ruin their life they
can still do everything they want to do
but they just can't do the one thing
that Society
hates them for
yeah I I definitely see that point of
view I think that many would believe
that that's cruel and unusual punishment
is there a different way about I know I
know what you're thinking I know the
only reason I say that is is part of my
research I bumped into this advocacy
organization and it's called prison
families Alliance
and I co-facilitate sex offender groups
families of sex offenders support it's
called support for families of sex
offenders and
the primary audience that shows up twice
a month on Zoom from all across the
United States
females right mothers some some sex
offenders that have transitioned out in
our own halfway houses Etc sometimes
they log on
but these mothers
are in so much pain
because of the collateral damage that
their sons have caused and a lot of it
is pornography
clicking on the wrong button mining down
in the middle of the night and on a
computer clicking into a sex trafficking
website
convicted sex offender
so now these mothers are saying what can
I do to help my son
How can I
make this better how can he's he's
19. he's 28 he's 34.
I don't believe that any of those
mothers would say castration is the
answer
that's a good point
so I think that's where the tears come
in maybe
yeah yeah the different tiers of sex
offenders yeah it's not a
one-size-fits-all right and it's I think
it's easy to paint with that that
broadband like down in St Petersburg
there are a whole lot of sex offenders
convicted in in the they had they were
forced to live in this trailer park or
places like it
that were
20 year old kids who met a girl who told
him that she was of age she was actually
15 16.
and next you know he got caught in a
he got caught
yeah my dad definitely didn't fit the
age range of you know being a 60 plus
sex offender not that he didn't fit but
in in terms of getting convicted and and
going to prison so late because
certainly he got away with it you know
for all those years which is a tragedy
in and of itself because there are so
many people including my family members
and Friends
if possibly they would have spoken up I
mean they spoke up when I wrote this
book
I I'm over 50. this happened to my
friend when we were in grade school
she said nothing to me
nothing to my father why was that
I think a lot of victims don't tell the
story but a lot of victims like me who
have fathers who are convicted sex
offenders also don't tell the story
so I think that the danger is living in
silence you know that's where shame
thrives in silence
and it took me over 20 years to not only
tell my story but to write a book and I
I'm now speaking at several universities
to criminology classes I spoke to a
prevent child abuse America conference
these are future DCFS workers and nurses
and social workers people in the field
who see the victims clinically
and that's a whole different segment and
how they their interpretive lands and
how they view sex offenders
and then I'll address a victimization
class or criminology class or a social
justice class at University of Illinois
or Eastern Illinois University or North
Central College and these are students
who are studying to become Corrections
Officers
private investigators and when I start
my presentations in that academic
environment which is my bag I love that
population I say who was a sex offender
what what optic comes to mind when you
think of a sex offender
and students can be very transparent and
and very candid and they'll raise their
hand or they'll shut out loud trash
scum
disgusting
and then I hold up a picture of my
father
and sometimes I'll joke and say did you
read the book
but most the time I'll say well this is
this is my father
he was a marathon runner he was a
husband over 25 years he was a
successful corporate executive he was a
sex offender
and then it inverts that perception
it educates it informs it opens up a
dialogue and sometimes
in those groups of students sometimes
victims of sex offenders will either
email me
or I give out my phone or phone number
text me
and say I haven't told anyone this and
since I was seven or eight or nine and
I'm telling you so now all of a sudden
I'm the recipient
of people who um are victims and that
has definitely been a shift I didn't
necessarily set out to tell my story for
that to happen but it's not only people
divulging and sharing and getting it off
their chest but it's other deviations of
that it's well my husband cheated on me
and I needed to tell you that because I
haven't you know now that I know that
your dad was a sex offender I feel I
like you even more I can tell you
anything you're fallible right because I
think that we all put on a mask as
humans when we move around in the world
and we want to be seen a certain way
but there's there's perception and
there's reality right so I think
hopefully my book can be a touchstone to
people who are walking around in the
grocery store or out in the street or at
a football game and it's someone
multiple people are suffering at that
football game
you just don't know it
because I'm not going to bring up that
my father is incarcerated while I'm
leading a Girl Scout meeting or a leader
on the parent board at school or at a
cocktail party or walking my kids to
school our daughters knew nothing that
my father was incarcerated
and that's a choice that we made not
everyone makes that choice but we made
that and that was hard to to carry that
burden was hard to carry what was the
most important lesson for for us all to
consider when we're
dealing with this topic
I think
um
when you're thinking about sex offenders
I think that
you need to be more open
and less closed off and quick to judge
I think that tolerance and acceptance
again not for the crime it's not what
I'm advocating
but
that individual who committed that
heinous act of Deceit
and disgusting Behavior who made that
choice
made it for a reason something inside
is is not right it's not happening is
they need help
and how can we help people that are on
the margins that are invisible that we
pardon when we're hating them when we're
hating them how can you help people when
you hate them yeah
how can we help someone who we he
believes so strongly is our enemy
which I understand
but as a as a daughter of a sex offender
who has carried that collateral damage
for so long
it's it's hard to to carry that
and it's important to let other people
know that they're not alone
as a victim or a perpetrator
all right Danica thank you so much for
informing us on all this this is very
interesting thank you for having me
thank you very much